翻訳: Kaori Muramatsu
校正: Mari Arimitsu
（拍手）
いかがでしたでしょうか
今 演奏した曲は『ちはやぶる』といいます
『ちはやぶる』というのは
日本の古い言葉で
大いなる力が 激しく
揺れ動いている様子を表しています
ちょっとね
息が上がっていますが
私は和太鼓に向かい合うと
つい自分のすべてを
ばーんと投げ出してしまうんですね
そこそこの力で演奏できない
全力をいつも出してしまいます
なぜかというと…
その前に ちょっと
子供の頃の話をさせて下さい
私は子供の頃 とても内気で
スポーツも大の苦手でした
ですから 和太鼓も
好きで始めたわけではありません
10歳の頃 親に連れられて
イヤイヤながら
近所の太鼓教室に行ったのが最初です
ですから 人前で演奏するなんて
本当に恥ずかしくてですね
その頃の写真なんですけれども
うつむいて本当にイヤそうなんですけれども
ところがです 中学生の時に
ある大きな変化がありました
あるイベントで演奏をした時に
自分の中から何かがですね
ブワァーッと出てきたんですよ
もう気がついたら
太鼓を打ちまくっているんですね
疲れても疲れても
勝手に体が動くんですよ
その時 何か目に見えない力に
自分が操られているようでした
なぜ私が和太鼓に向かうと
全部を投げ出してしまうのか？
最初の問いですけれども
それは 私が和太鼓に
全力で向かうことで
自分というところから飛び出して
より大きな世界と
響き合うことができるからなんです
打っても打っても尽きることのない
無限の力を感じることができるからなんです
30年前 和太鼓がー
内気な私を解き放ってくれた
その体験が今も
私をつき動かしているんです
ところで この和太鼓なんですけれども
皮の部分は牛の皮です
胴は大きな木をくり抜いてできています
いわば命をいただいてできている
生きている楽器です
ですから あなたと私が違うように
太鼓もひとつとして同じものはありません
あなたが暑ければ汗をかいて
寒ければ鳥肌が立つように
太鼓も温度や湿度 環境によって
いつも響きが変わります
あなたがこれまで歳を重ねてきたように
太鼓も年を経るごとに
その響きを 深みを増していきます
太鼓を打つ演奏者が変われば
出てくる響きも もちろん変わります
また 生きている和太鼓の響きには
たくさんのノイズが
含まれているんですね
そのノイズが和太鼓の響きを
とても豊かなものにしています
ノイズを余計なものやムダと捉えずに
受け入れることで
自分の考えも及ばない
あなた方が思いもよらないような
新たな世界が開いていくんです
生きているものはー
ノイズも含んだ全体が
留まることなく変化をし続けています
この「流れてゆく変化」を
私は「響き」と呼んでいます
「生きている」ということは
「響いている」ということなんです
つまり響きとは
命そのものなんです
今日 私がここで
皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
あなた自身や あなたが今
捉えているこの世界は
留まることのない
変化の中にあるということ
そして響き合っているんだということです
あなたが もしこれから
何か壁にぶつかった時に
そのことを思い出して下さい
「この世界は響きに満ちあふれているのだ」
ということを
その響きの中に あらゆる可能性が
秘められているんです
大丈夫です
ただ思い出せばいいんです
それが未来をひらく大きな力になると
私は信じています
最後に『たまゆら』という曲を演奏して
終わりにしたいと思います
「たまゆら」とは
まが玉とまが玉が
カチーンと触れ合った時の
「ほんの一瞬」とか
「わずかな」という意味があります
この小さい太鼓
たったひとつの中からー
あふれてくる さまざまな響きに
あなたを委ねてみて下さい
あなたの魂は 無限のものと
いつも繋がり 響き合っています
あなたが響きそのもので
あなたの響きが
この世界を創っているのです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）